grayscale is adding solana to one of
their funds now what is so fascinating
about this is it took years from 2014 i
believe is when grayscale got launched
it took years to get institutional
investors interested in bitcoin to get
them into these institutional quality
funds whether it was gbtc uh in a
publicly traded trust or in some sort of
private company but or a private fund
now grayscale is quickly quickly quickly
adding new types of assets solana
uniswap etc they've added it to their
digital large cap fund which has about
494 million about 500 million dollars in
it there is a a fun component breakdown
that i believe we have and when you
start to look at this uh list of assets
these are not the assets that you would
think that institutions would likely be
buying but to have 500 million dollars
in the fund is way more than i would
have thought so we see everything from
bitcoin cardano uniswap litecoin
ethereum solana chain link bitcoin cash
etc when you have a large entity like
grayscale which manages 30 40 billion
dollars of assets and they begin to add
the long tail to it their institutional
clients whether people like it or not
they are going to start to expand what
they're investing in from bitcoin to
other types of assets we know that they
have a bitcoin trust they have an
ethereum trust they also have other
types of individual asset trusts but
what you see here is a digital large cap
fund now it's not surprising because
something like a solana wasn't in the
top ten then it goes into the top ten if
you look at a company like bitwise where
i'm an investor they essentially create
passive indexes so they have something
called the bitwise 10. now what is the
bitwise 10 it's the 10 largest cap
assets on a market weight basis and they
rebalance it on a periodic basis and so
naturally what you're going to get is
you're going to have long only single
asset investors i buy bitcoin i hold it
for a long period of time uh those at
those are the investors that have
dominated the market for a long time
then we started to get active traders
people who would come in and they would
buy and sell some day trading some a
little bit less periodic but still the
ability to buy low sell high and do that
over and over and over again now what
we're seeing is a rise in more and more
passive vehicles so things like top 10
of the market cap or certain sectors
similar to what we see in the etf or the
passive index space and so if it happens
in the legacy market it's going to
happen in this market as well we've got
a quote here from grayskills head of
legal it says we will sell the existing
fund components in proportion to their
ratings and then put in solana and
unison the fund is really a great way
for our investors who don't want to make
a targeted bet on bitcoin ethereum or
another digital asset they just really
want broad market exposure and so what
we are likely to see is some of the
capital that's going to come into the
market they no longer want to play
security selection right they simply
just say i want to have crypto exposure
whether we like it or we don't we think
it's positive or negative those
investors are going to demand
broad-based
exposure in an index and so naturally if
there is demand companies are going to
build these types of products do we
think that this is a positive or a
negative for the industry and are we
surprised that more and more people want
broad-based index exposure
no i don't think so i don't think we
should be surprised i think it uh it
limits your downside a little bit right
like on the risk curve if you look at it
uh kind of having exposure to everything
in aggregate sure maybe you should have
conviction on kind of one or two assets
that you really believe in but if your
if your general idea is that these
assets are going to all appreciate in
value and there's too many of them for
you to really pick and choose from and
you don't know which ones are going to
be the winners and you just want a
little exposure to the market and the
upside of kind of the asymmetry that
this uh kind of asset class offers then
sure i think it's uh it's probably a
smart decision to be able to invest in a
vehicle like this john what do you think
it's a no-brainer i don't see it being a
negative to the industry at all same
thing as uh almost like an etf in my
mind where you get that exposure across
just the entire asset class
i uh i'm personally bullish real big on
bitcoin so having the other ones in
there um i don't own any of this but
it's interesting to see and i can see
why people rush to it and why uh they
are constantly adding and removing
things based on the market size and uh
the market cap of the different assets
i think if anything it's good for solana
and uniswap right well yeah
like outside of kind of just like
industry looking trends and all that
kind of stuff like it's obviously good
for these uh kind of these individual
assets to be included in the broad base
index
the other piece of it is
when i think about the broad base
indexes is i actually have more
confidence that investors allocating to
those indexes are unlikely to sell
because they're literally just looking
over a long period of time let me invest
into a lower cost index just give me
kind of the industry and they're not
going to worry so much about what one
individual asset goes up or down in
price versus if i do security selection
right or the idea of kind of a single
asset selection if i buy a bitcoin or
buy ethereum then all of a sudden i
start to get in the mindset of like oh i
bought bitcoin uh but maybe uh wait it
went down ten percent this other one
went up maybe i should switch or i
bought another one oh that one went down
this one went up i should switch and so
the index type exposure gives me hope
and again we'll see that they're longer
term stronger hands which ultimately is
a greater tailwind for the entire
industry yeah and i think uh kind of to
your point right is like if you just
want there's certainly investors uh
whether they're kind of institutional
investors or retail investors that just
want one two three four five percent
exposure into the industry right they
don't want to put all their capital at
work uh in digital assets they want a
bunch of other stocks a bunch of other
stuff whether it's stocks bonds etc
and they just want that little bit of
exposure to get off zero right and i
think this is a vehicle that you could
quickly see why they would invest into
it uh so they don't have to go out and
pick a certain asset and say hey look
this is gonna be the winner i'm gonna
put all my percent in this or kind of
all my capital in this instead i'm gonna
go over here and get broad-based
exposure to the industry and hope over
the next five 10 15 years that it
appreciates in value and it's a small
part of their uh portfolio in general so
yeah to your point they're not gonna go
out and be actively day trading this
stuff they're not gonna be selling it
all the time they're gonna let it sit
there and see if it appreciates overtime